good morning believe nation today's
message is find something that people
need over to you Mike judge the job is a
fairly recent concept in human history
it used to be that you know you'd be the
blacksmith in the village or you'd be
the guy who makes horseshoes or
furniture and you know business was good
or business was bad but you weren't
worried about unemployment you know like
the Vikings weren't worried about
unemployment jobs and I think in tough
economic times if you can't find a job
or if you find like I did that you just
don't like most of the jobs I would
encourage you to go back to that older
way of thinking you know find something
people need or want willing to pay for I
found that people needed and wanted to
watch to dumbass teenagers sitting on
the couch watching bad music videos you
know hopefully you'll find something
more high-minded I guess but tough
economic times like this have inspired
people to do really great things and
start their own businesses and find new
ways you know to do business so we've
talked about this over and over and over
again on the channel but the most basic
principle in business is that you need
to provide value if you want to make
money if you want to get money you want
to get paid as an entrepreneur you want
to have success is gonna come from
giving other people value and that could
be in the form of entertainment like
Mike judge did and he has these cartoons
that people watch and they laugh that's
value it could be in the form of utility
and you're helping teach somebody
something it could be in the form of
helping them solve a problem right if
people are finding value in what you're
doing then they will pay you for it and
the more guys you can provide the more
money you're gonna make
often that value comes from scratching
your own itch it comes from you looking
for something you need to know that you
trying to solve a problem and because
that doesn't exist then you go and
create it you know I created this book
because I wanted this solution and it
didn't exist
but he had written that book so I went
out and did the research and then just
compiled it together for you guys to
enjoy too but I've used everything in
the book to help me build my business
the top ten series and the in stressful
series and the believe life series
basically every video on this channel I
made for me because I want to learn to
get better as an entrepreneur and so
we're doing the research and compiling
it selfishly for me and I'm sharing that
with you so because it gives value for
me it's likely there's gonna be an
audience that other people will have the
same problem and you can help solve it
for them as well so the easiest way to
get started to think about the problems
that you have right now and if it's not
being met then that's an opportunity
because there's probably other people in
the world who have that exact same
problem and are searching for a solution
that you can provide so the question
that today is what are you providing
that people really need leave in the
comments below and I will join in the
discussion I'd also like to give a quick
shout out to Simeon Coast a Dean of hope
I pronounced that properly thank you so
much you're picking up a copy of my book
it really means a lot to me for those of
you watching who want a chance at a
future shadow in the next video make
sure you pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
you